5 avec serge cimino maintenant et
patrick mille hors-ue découvrons
quelques secrets de cette pyramide
la pyramide livre enfin ses secrets et
le grand louvre voit le jour en sous-sol
nouveaux espaces et beaucoup de
mouvements de notions clés des
installations sous pyramide pour
permettre un redéploiement des oeuvres
du palais du louvre à redéploiement qui
passe par l'extension de nouveaux lieux
comme par exemple dans le palais
l'ouverture sur plus de 2500 m² de 12
nouvelles salles où sont exposés les
collections des peintures françaises des
primitifs au xviie siècle
quant à la pyramide elle accueillera de
nouveaux espaces muséaux logique mais
aussi un auditorium des boutiques des
restaurants et une bibliothèque en tout
cas avant de connaître le sentiment des
futurs visiteurs l'architecte a le
sourire en ce jour inaugural
je suis très satisfait parce que je
pense que les français sont en train
d'accepter ce projet mais je pense
qu'ils l'accepteront encore mieux
lorsqu'ils l'auront visiteurs la
nouveauté sous la pyramide ce sont les
fossés du louvre médiéval et douves du
château de charles 5 et du donjon de
philippe auguste où sont exposés divers
objets provenant des fouilles
archéologiques de la cour carrée mais le
louvre joue aussi la carte des
expositions temporaires avec un espace
de 1200 m² aménageable la première
exposition sera consacrée aux donateurs
du louvre enfin une autre initiative
pour attirer les visiteurs
certaines salles seront accessibles tous
les jours de la semaine jusqu'à 22
heures sauf le mardi et ça ce n'est pas
une nouveauté mais le louvre n'a pas
fini pour autant de déménager le
ministère des finances par pour bercy en
juillet 89 l'achèvement du projet est en
fait prévu pour 1997